[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
located baby eagle
huh
[Applause]
i guess you me
picked the wrong spot to vacation eh
you will receive our most sacred body
it begins
now
if i could just forget what happened
that night
the pain
even for a second
this time
it can be different
it has to
state of play returns and we've got some
great playstation updates to share with
you today
and thanks to capcom for kicking it off
with resident evil 4 coming to ps5 with
playstation vr2 content also in
development
now let's get a sneak peek at four games
in development for playstation vr2
ah now
let's take a look at him
wow well ethan winters
you escaped my little brother's idiot
games did you
let's see how special you are
yes
okay
[Music]
man blood oh be careful what you wish
what are you doing
[Music]
[Music]
you
of all people have the audacity to
question me
you
who emerged from the putrid waters of
the bible
to plunder our righteous gains and cut
our throats like a demon in the night
what have you done to ensure the future
of this forsaken city
you
who have brought nothing but chaos
when death was swallowing this city hall
it was i who resurrected it it was i who
shined as a beacon of hope for all
the tower cries out for blood
and i vow to spell it
when the bells ring the song they sing
will be righteous
welcome home
tourist
[Music]
um
[Music]
there
where are you taking me
[Music]
i asked you a question
everyone says reyes is a good shot yeah
and i'll put arrows through both of us
you're switching with me
it's a snap
we're not gonna make it
[Music]
blameless maraud had been released from
prison
but why
redemption is
climb the mountain
[Music]
find out why the machines are attacking
[Applause]
do that
and you shall be a free man
it will take all your wits
your skills
and courage
you have walked in the shadows reyes
[Music]
now it is time to climb
into the light
hi i'm ben mccaw narrative director at
gorilla
i hope you enjoyed your first look at
horizon call of the mountain coming
exclusively to playstation vr2 we're
also happy to announce that a big update
to horizon forbidden west including new
game plus will be available to download
on playstation 4 and playstation 5 today
for details on this free update please
check out playstation blog from all of
us at gorilla thank you for your
continued support and please stay tuned
for more updates to come
[Music]
get ready a playstation fan favorite is
coming to pc
[Music]
these past few years
sacrificing so much and asking for
nothing if you want to change the world
you have to be the kind of man
who can make the hardest decisions
do you really need two of those
you are everything that's wrong with
this city
i'm gonna go uh
do your thing
you can't just push people around like
that
just ask for help next time time to
bring back the glory days
did you just leave your clothes on the
kitchen floor
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
explore a mysterious cyber city in stray
coming to ps5 and ps4 july 19th
playstation plus extra members in hire
can download stray at no extra cost when
it launches next month
up next three games that will get your
heart racing
[Music]
[Music]
take a look outside
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead
just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
so whatever you're holding on to right
there
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your new life
is entirely
in my hands
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time
[Applause]
[Music]
in the year 2030
a new blood sport grips the globe
[Music]
and in the arena
there will only be the victorious
and the dead
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the world is watching
[Music]
sometimes
i wonder
if things will ever be normal again
[Music]
the world hasn't ended yet it's not
hopeless
i won't let anyone else get hurt
don't you want science in your corner
[Music]
oh you
i'm going to miss them
i look forward to seeing what you can do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
action games and dating sims collide in
eternites coming to ps5 and ps4 next
year
let's check back in with capcom for a
new look at an upcoming heavy hitter
when you go looking for strength
it's not like a game
this journey doesn't have a real ending
okay then hope you're ready to begin
if you want to start off on the right
foot in this city hit the streets
never fear losing and when i get up in
the game you're up here improve a real
problem but i solve them all fast proof
and if you think i'm going forward and
you talking fool
[ __ ]
[Music]
moving
[Music]
[Applause]
show me
me
[Music]
this is our destiny
street fighter 6.
[Music]
that was your first look at street
fighter 6 game play mark your calendars
it comes to ps5 and ps4 in
2023 now it's time for two indie
adventures arriving later this year
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she set out to record life at the end of
this season
to make it real for people in the future
she asked us about living together
[Music]
and we asked her about traveling alone
when the season turns
what will remain
only what she saw
what she captured
she carries the sounds of the season
with her
[Music]
the way she listened made you want to
tell her everything
i got to look in her journal
the world was telling her it's secrets
i think she even figured out
what will happen to us
when the season ends
is it going
[Music]
is it gone
[Music]
not yet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
so
who are we
what are the dominance
the power we wield
it wears away at our very being
it breaks us
it unmakes us
that its immaculate aspect might reveal
itself
the icon
there's going to be another war isn't
there
every day we delay brings us closer to
disaster
we must move now
the chaos he would wreak would sweep all
of vallasthea into the abyss
[Music]
i unite the dominance
that we may bring an end to the strife
and found a new order to see us onto
tomorrow
if i take the field
our duels shake the island
to its foundations
so
[Music]
there will be losses it is true
yet for every citizen who falls
another can be bred
every home that burns another can be
built
the empire will live on
[Music]
awakened child of fate
awakened everything
[Music]
and that's a wrap don't forget to visit
playstation blog to learn even more
about today's announcements see you next
time
[Music]
playstation